well I think Andrew McCabe has made a  fool out of himself over the last couple  of days and he really looks to me like  sort of a poor man's J Edgar Hoover he's  a I think it's a disaster and what he  was trying to do was terrible and he was  caught I'm very proud to say we caught  him so we'll see what happens but he he  is a disgraced man he was terminated not  like me he was terminated by others the  IG report was a disaster a disaster from  his standpoint anybody reading the IG  report would say how could a man like  this be involved with the FBI  and the FBI has some of the greatest  people some of the finest people you'll  ever meet but this man is a complete  disaster thank you all very much thank  you